well you may have noticed there is an
election campaign going on and joining
me here in the studio sky Nissan red
studio is the Prime Minister David
Cameron pretty good morning see you
how's it going so far
well it's been been going well I think
yesterday I think we set out a very
clear choice for people you know stick
with the team that are delivering jobs
and growth and livelihoods that have
turned the country around
or put it at risk with admit about well
you see there you go again I mean you
had that you liked your cricket don't
you I do like your cricket a mare you
were outside Downing Street and you have
a swipe but I fell apart and then you're
at it again this morning a lot of people
would say it's not cricket and you use
the wrong place yesterday I don't agree
with that I mean in cricket there are
two opposing teams there's a choice and
that's the same in politics oh I will
defend my record over the last five
years and I will talk a lot about that
during the campaign you had but it was
also it's also an advantage you see
there's you outside number ten than
those who might say too sweet ice there
and you look all grand and planners
astareal or whatever a lot of people are
saying you know ed should have a right
of reply there to do that a lot of
people also saying if you want to get
personal with them why didn't you do it
head-to-head why didn't you do it and
they in the first well we've done yet a
hundred and forty six Prime Minister's
Questions I think together I wanted to
get on with those debates well before
the election campaign for all sorts of
reasons the broadcaster's didn't go with
that so in the end we had this sort of
log jam and I broke that by saying come
on there let's just have the one big
debate that's going to happen on
Thursday and so we've got that underway
but I think that's good well was it good
because then you had Paxil and he wasn't
in good form you come on and he clubs
you a bit like a seal he hits you over
the head with the big sticks because
what he does I think that's what he does
but did you not suddenly think I wish
had just had have gone head to head but
there'd because it wouldn't be as tough
as this no I think it's good to be
grilled by interviewers by studio
audiences I think a lot of an election
campaign should be that as well as
traveling around the country I thought
the problem last time was that the
debates were valuable but the campaign
was only about the debates there was
really no other comment than you know
the warm-up to the debates the debates
themselves and so some of the issues
were pushed out the way and the issues
at this election are immense
we either continue with a plan that's
working with getting the country back to
work we've pledged today two million
jobs in the next parliament because
we're going to continue at the rate of
creating 10,000 jobs a day and we
believe we've got the way of doing that
because of the way we've encouraged
business to come here we've made Britain
a great place to invest those are the
issues I want to talk about rather than
simply talk about performances in a TV
the role issues aren't that your
Heinie's as it were you've got the
economy but wouldn't put it that way and
you've got ads it's all easy well the
the point about the economy and
employment is without a strong economy
all the other things we want to achieve
in politics the strong health service
better schools for our children building
more homes for young people to buy and
own those things aren't possible unless
you have the bedrock of the strong
economy and that's why I will be
reminding people in this campaign five
years ago when I first walked through
that black door you know people were
wondering would Britain be able to pay
the debts well we can be able to get out
of the economic mile we were in we'll be
able to create jobs again we've answered
those questions and my message is very
clear
stick to the plan it isn't finished yet
and we need to see it through but yes
you're right it isn't finish it because
you weren't banking on a coalition van
are you banking on a coalition
no I'm not we are 23 seats short I want
to be able to say that without getting
mush is wrong 23 seats short of a
majority we can form a majority
government if the British people backers
and I think the British people want a
majority government for this reason that
the coalition government did some good
work but majority government is more
accountable what I put in my manifesto
is the program for the government
nothing gets haggled away in backroom
deals and I think people want that
clarity that's certainty that
accountability from the election and the
at what's plan B for the next 37 days
there is no plan B I'm going to tell me
you're not having secret talks with I'm
not having a collab with all I don't
have time I barely have time to have
talks with my wife let alone talks with
anyone else so what I'm going to be
doing for 37 days is flat out to win the
majority that I think would be best for
our country because the best way to
continue with the plan that's working is
to put me back into Downing Street with
the team George Osborne Theresa
may all the others the team that have
delivered this strong performance for
Britain and and these jobs are you going
to deliver these jobs well by making
sure we keep taxes down on business and
today labor that's one of your East
they're saying they're going to put up
taxes on business what a crazy thing to
do when the economy is growing we're
going to make sure we go on building
this infrastructure the road and rail
investment which is now the highest it's
been for decades we're going to train
three million apprentices in the next
parliament because I don't want young
people to leave school and start a life
on the dole when you leave school you
should be either earning or learning and
if we take those steps stick to the path
were on there's no reason why we can't
go on creating a thousand jobs a day in
the next parliament just as we have in
this Parliament well if if you win and
you do get into the next Parliament why
would you want that job why would you
want to go down in history as the
biggest Scrooge Prime Minister that
there has ever been because there's
dirty deeds to be done ahead there's a
lot of hard work to be done but what my
I didn't come into politics to you know
be someone who had to make lots of cuts
and reductions but that is you know you
become Prime Minister and you have to do
the job that needs to be done when I
became prime minister in 2010 Britain
was on the brink we had a budget deficit
bigger forecast to be bigger than
Greece's and we needed to take
responsibility and I wanted to get our
deficit down without putting up taxes
for hardworking people and you know when
that we can show clearly how we do that
in the next parliament and that's about
being responsible why can't you show us
clearly know why can't you tell us not
how you're going to make those cuts is
it because the medicine is just too
horrible to swallow now let me the
medicine is way I describe it is that we
need to for two more years do what we've
done for the last five which is fine
one pound out of every 100 the
government spends and save it and the
choice at this election if you simplify
it really is do you want to find that
one pound saving out of every hundred
which families and businesses up and
down the country have had to do or do
you want to scrap that plan and put up
taxes or borrow more instead that's
really the choice I think we can find
that one pound
Adam every hundred in this Parliament we
found twenty billion pounds of savings
just by making government more efficient
making sure the IT systems work that
property wasn't bought bad rates you
know proper efficiency like businesses
do like sky does every year we also
found twenty billion of welfare savings
in this Parliament by taking difficult
decisions making sure work always paid
and we need to go on making those sorts
of decisions in the next parliament but
again it's a choice you either say yes
let's reform welfare and reduce the
costs or let's scrap that and put up
taxes and that's the alternative the
other decision that you come up with is
that if successful you wouldn't stand
for a third term and I begin influence
was your wife and family on that it
wasn't about that I just gave a straight
answer to a straight question which is
I've always believed in serving a full
second term I've said that many times
but I thought what follows from that is
you're on a serve a full second term you
might as well be clear about a third
term and I think I want people to know
the sort of person I am I think
political leadership is vital I believe
I'm halfway through the job that I want
to do for our country but I think after
that you know no one should think
they're indispensable I think but I'm
not saying all as I put it all Prime
Minister's go mad or necessarily go mad
at the same rate but I think there is a
time when it's good to see some some
fresh legs thank you very much indeed
Prime Minister our time is up now
whether your time's up will be
determined in a few weeks time and but
for the moment thank you very much
indeed and I've said to you'll send
everybody have a good campaign think
thank you very much indeed